it was just a lie I can't fly I can't
even run
crows are all liars I know a story about
the crow
crowd
in A Song of Ice and Fire Brand has
visited several times in its trains by a
mysterious crow with a third eye atop
its head it's not until the fifth book A
Dance with Dragons that we finally see
his true form deep within the earth
beneath an ancient weirwood tree he
waits though his body has withered with
extreme age he is kept alive by the
weirwood which he himself has become a
part of the roots of the tree have grown
through him his body is so skeletal and
pale that brand mistakes him for corpse
the first time he sees him Bloodraven
actually has quite a history he's
actually a Targaryen bastard that was
born well over a hundred years before
bran was born he was sent to the wall by
King Aegon v late in the year 233 AC for
killing a nice black fire while under
safe conduct
even though effectively he ended the
Blackfyre rebellion by doing so
Bloodraven remains a member of the
Nights Watch for 19 years
he even becomes Lord Commander before he
mysteriously vanishes beyond the wall in
252 AC he's never seen or heard from
again we know for sure that Bloodraven
appears in the dreams of at least two
characters in our story bran and Jojen
Reed and if you've seen my understanding
the birth of dragons video then you know
that I believe that he also may have
visited Dany in a similar way but with
less effect possibly due to distance at
the wall Milla saundra sees Bloodraven
in her flames
she obviously senses his power because
at first she confuses him with the great
other himself
she wondered if it had been his face
that she had seen staring out at her
from the flames no surely not his
village would be more frightening than
that cold and black and too terrible for
any man to gaze upon and live the wooden
man she had glimpsed though and the boy
with the wolf's face there were his
servants surely it's important to note
that bloodraven can also see Melisandre
and this seems to frighten her a face
took shape within the hearth stannis she
thought for just a moment but no these
were not his features a wooden face
corpse white was this the enemy a
thousand red eyes floated in the flames
he sees me beside him a boy with a
wolf's face threw back his head and
howled
the red priestess shuddered
some have theorized that bloodraven uses
crows to watch the world outside of his
cave but I don't think he's limited of
him according to mill isandro he can see
her through the flames and there were no
Ravens or crows present even before he
was sent to the wall Bloodraven was
thought by many to be a sorcerer and
there is reason to believe that he
hadn't been a powerful skin-changer even
before he disappeared beyond the wall
how many is his lord Bloodraven had the
riddle ran a thousand eyes in one some
claim the Kings hand was a student of
the dark arts who could change his face
put on the likeness of a one-eyed dog
even turn into mist packs of gaunt gray
wolves hunted down his foes men said and
carrion crows spied for him and
whispered secrets in his ear we know
that the children of the forest can use
weirwood trees to watch the world as
well could it be that the combination of
the two leads to enhanced ability so if
he's so powerful than what does he need
with brain in the prologue of a Dance
with Dragons we get a glimpse into the
mind of a dying warg by the name of very
mere six skins as he contemplates his
life he is comforted only by the fact
that he knows he will live a second life
through his wolf but when his companion
Thistle whom he thought had abandoned
him returns out of desperation he
attempts to inhabit her body and force
her out of her own skin this seems to
set up Jon Snow's resurrection in the
books quite nicely but what if Jon Snow
is a red herring
we know that blood Raven is at least 120
years old and the weirwood gives him
life still he seems to be withering
could he want to still branch body seems
interesting but then why is blood raven
showing bran has passed through the
trees well he could just be buying time
for the weirwood to become more
connected to brand once bran had spent
enough time being one with the weirwood
it would likely be easier for blood
Raven to steal brand's body but why
would Bloodraven be doing this well I
don't think he has very much control
over the situation it's the children of
the forest who are the culprits here so
that may mean the blood
isn't attempting to steal brands body at
all maybe bran is simply his replacement
why would Brynden rivers the Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch end up in
a cave surrounded by the children of the
forest beyond the wall
we know that Bloodraven had an interest
in magic I've suggested before that the
children may have lured him into the
cave the same way that he lured brain
and once he was there they used him for
his power if Bloodraven can see
Melisandre without the presence of a
raven or a weirwood tree what else can
he see after the invasion of the Andals
all the weirwood trees not in the north
were chopped down this would certainly
lower the power of the children as they
use them to watch mankind it seems as
though the children could be using blood
Ravens power as simply a tool for their
own agenda the children have a plot one
that's been decades in the making if
you've seen my videos the origin of the
others and why we can't trust the
children then you know that I believe
that initially some of the children
broke off from the group and became the
others when things went too far the
remaining children that didn't become
the others help the first men defeat the
others though they did seem hesitant
only waiting till mankind was at its
most desperate to intervene even though
they clearly knew how to defeat the
others could the reluctance have been
due to the fact that they knew that
others work into them it's hinted in the
books that the children may have some
trouble reproducing as well much like
the others seem to the gods gave us long
lives but not great numbers lest we
overrun the world as deer will overrun a
wood where there are no wolves to hunt
them the long night was a thousand years
ago before the Andals invaded and nearly
finished off the children of the forest
completely now the others are returning
again and I believe this is because the
remaining children have decided to join
the side with the remaining others to
take back Westeros from humanity the
attacks of the others are fairly recent
seemingly they started within the last
few years but Craster has been
sacrificing his sons to the white
walkers for decades it seems and in a
storm of sores before Sam escapes
Craster's keep one of the wives refer to
the others as crest her son this could
imply that cross their sons are being
turned
the White Walkers and I think it does
but wait I thought the children of the
forest were the ones who became the
White Walkers yes they were but as a
Dance with Dragons mentions they're
almost completely gone now they likely
couldn't risk it after what happened
last time
so they used crafts or sons instead the
White Walkers aren't a threat to the
children it seems they clearly have
magical protection against them and we
know that the children hunted with
dragonglass daggers long before men
arrived in Westeros since the children
have to use humans this time it makes
sense that they would need a human in
order to control them this would seem to
be the purpose of blood Raven blood
Ravens power is now a part of the
weirwood his mind may be under the
control of the children as well he is
their prisoner mind and body but only
for as long as the weirwood can extend
his life that's why they needed brain
skin changers as powerful as bran or
bloodraven don't come along very often
the children have every reason to want
to reclaim what is theirs men have
brought nothing but destruction and
horror to the world the White Walkers
are the children's tool against humanity
and they have every reason and right to
want mankind gone where are the rest of
you bran asked lief once gone down into
the earth into the stones into the trees
before the first men came all this land
you call Westeros was home to us yet
even in those days we were few the gods
gave us love lives but not great numbers
lest we overrun the world as deer were
overrun a wood where there are no wolves
to hunt them that was in the dawn of
days when our Sun was rising now it
sinks and this is our long dwindling the
Giants are almost gone as well they who
were our Bane and our brothers
the Great Lions of the western hills
have been all but slain the unicorns are
gone the mammoths down to a few hundred
the dire wolves will outlast us all but
their time will come as well and the
world that men have made there is no
more room for them o us thank you guys
for watching make sure you subscribe and
check out my other videos for more ideas
of ice and fire in that darkness the
others came for the first time they were
cold things dead things that hated iron
and fire and the touch of the Sun and
every creature with hot blood in its
veins they swept over holdfasts and
cities and kingdoms felled heroes and
armies by the score